herzlich willkommen zum zdf heute live
stream ihrem aktuellen live stream zu
allen sachen die gerade aktuell auf der
welt passieren und wir haben uns vor
einer woche ging ja die bilder durch die
nachrichten ticker und um die welt von
bränden lager moria auf der insel lesbos
13.000 menschen waren dort unter
schwierigen bedingungen untergebracht
und waren quasi über nacht obdachlos
geworden und dann ging die diskussion
los wohin mit diesen menschen die
griechische regierung wollte sie am
liebsten auf der insel lassen neue zelte
bauen
in deutschland wurde viel diskutiert ob
man menschen aufnehmen können wenn ja
wie viele und am wochenende ist dort ein
richtiger koalitionsstreit entbrannt
spd chefin saskia esken hat quasi der
regierung eine frist gesetzt 48 stunden
habe man um sich zu einigen sie wollte
eine hohe zweistellige zahl von menschen
aus griechenland aufnehmen heute gab es
dann tatsächlich eine einigung wir hören
uns mal an was finanzminister olaf
scholz und saskia esken die spd-chefin
dazu zu sagen haben sind 1500 etwa 1500
personen in familien mit kindern die
jetzt von allen inseln in griechenland
geholt werden und damit wird entlastung
überall möglich sein
die situation in moria wird dadurch auch
entlastung erfahren wir haben als
regierung eine verständigung
herbeigeführt über das was zu tun ist
das setzt fort die entscheidung der
letzten woche sich zu beteiligen an der
aufnahme von minderjährigen
unbegleiteten flüchtlingen die direkte
auf lesbos und bei dem der unterkunft
moria betroffen sind und wo wir gesagt
haben wir werden einen substanziellen
beitrag leisten was der fall ist
jetzt setzt sich das fort indem wir
sicherstellen dass 1553
familienangehörige die bereits anerkannt
sind die inseln verlassen können und so
ist es dann auch das ermöglicht dass wir
entspannung auf der konkreten situation
in moria bekommen was ein ganz wichtiger
und guter fortschritt ist und darüber
sprechen nicht gleich mit meinem
kollegen mathis feldhoff im
hauptstadtstudio berlin wir warten auch
darauf ob sich innenminister horst
seehofer von der csu im laufe unseres
teams noch einmal zu wort meldet dann
würden wir sofort hin schalten wir
wollen auch später noch mit niklas
fischer
von der ngo mission lifeline auf lesbos
sprechender dort vor ort ist dort soll
auch gerade jetzt zur stunde eine
demonstration von flüchtlingen und wipro
ngo staaten da gucken wir mal die lage
ist kommentare und fragen zum thema
natürlich immer gerne unten rein aber
wie immer bei diesem schwierigen thema
die bitte sachlich zu bleiben
und falls ihr oder sie fragen per e mail
schicken wollte auch dafür gibt es eine
adresse das ist zdf heute.de zdf.de so
jetzt komme ich aber zu meinem kollegen
mathis feldhoff ja schon ein bisschen
wartet dass er mit uns sprechen kann
halo mathis hallo
das haben wir gerade gehört 1553
flüchtlinge aus griechenland will die
bundesregierung aufnehmen
ist das jetzt viel oder ist das wenig es
hat sich ja vielleicht mal mit der
genese des tages zukommt hat sich heute
morgen angekündigt als angela merkel und
horst seehofer durchsickern haben lassen
dass es um diese 1500 menschen gehen
wird die mir jetzt aufnehmen will und
dann zu sagen die spd reagieren musste
am ende ist es doch wenig wir haben das
gehört 13.000 menschen auf lesbos die da
sozusagen jetzt auf der straße leben da
ist natürlich 1500 nur ein tropfen auf
den heißen stein
die bundesregierung der bus leon war es
wichtig in strom der unionsseite war es
wichtig das ist von allen griechischen
inseln jetzt auch flüchtlinge sind die
man aufnimmt weil auch auf anderen
griechischen insel natürlich lager gibt
die deren zustand bemerkenswert oder
bedauernswert ist und dass diese
flüchtlinge bereits anerkannt sind also
ein asylverfahren und ein ähnliches
kriegs flüchtlings anerkennungsverfahren
in griechenland durchlaufen hat und dann
hat man mit der griechischen regierung
diese 400 familien der identifiziert das
summiert sich dann auf insgesamt 1143
personen die jetzt in den nächsten
wochen über die habe die haupt über
griechenland also über die dass das land
griechenland dann auch nach deutschland
kommen sollen
wir haben es gerade gehört ich habe es
gesagt saskia esken hat quasi ein
ultimatum gestellt und hat gesagt die
wir brauchen eine einigung auf hatte sie
ja nicht ein druckmittel was hätte sie
machen können wenn ihr es nicht gekommen
wäre
naja das druckmittel sind vor allem die
bilder aus moriya das muss man deutlich
sagen das hat
auch wirkung hinterlassen auch in der
bundesregierung also die bundesregierung
hatte in einem ersten schritt schon mal
150 unbegleitete flüchtlinge aufgenommen
zugesagt dass ich sie aufnehmen werden
das hat sie zusammen mit zehn anderen
europäischen staaten getan insgesamt 400
davon dem die bundesregierung im
bundestag deutschland 150 auf das hat
horst seehofer am freitag verkündet aber
er hat dann auch gesagt es wird keine
weiteren schritte geben weil jeder
weitere einzelnen schritt von
deutschland würde dazu beitragen dass
eine gemeinsame europäische lösung am
ende nur scheitern würde saß gestern hat
das christkind hat dann am sonntag hier
im zdf berlin direkt von einer hohen
vierstelligen summe geredet die sie in
deutschland aufnehmen will und hat das
auch mit einer forderung an die union
verknüpft dass das jetzt geschehen am
montag nochmal den druck erhöht indem
sie dieses 48 stunden ultimatum in den
raum gestellt hat also am ende muss man
sagen ist auch volker es geändert obwohl
sie die koalition die union ein bisschen
vor sich her getrieben hat natürlich von
einer zahl von froh vierstellig da denkt
meine an acht bis 9000 doch auf 1500
zurückgefallen das ist dann was man
realpolitik nennt wahrscheinlich dass
das würdest du sagen ist jetzt kein
großer sieg für die spd die sich auf die
fahnen schreiben kann dass sie dafür
sorgt dass viele menschen von den
griechischen inseln runterkommen es ist
ein klassischer kompromiss wie in der
politik oft so dieses die sorge auch der
inter würde union das sozusagen sich
eine eine sagen welle aber es zeigt dass
sozusagen größere zahlen von
flüchtlingen sozusagen die stimmung in
deutschland wieder verändern können
natürlich sind neue selbst 9000
flüchtlinge von der ein land wie die
beruflich deutschland nicht besonders
viel das steckt dieses land jeden monat
ungefähr weg und keiner merkt es so
richtig natürlich jeden tag kommen
flüchtlinge es gehen auch jeden tag
wieder flüchtlinge also jeder prozess
ist ja ist ein sehr fließender aber es
hat es als große symbolische bedeutung
wenn man jetzt sagt wir neben 9000
flüchtlinge auf und das wollte die union
unbedingt verhindern es sollte eine
kleine vierstellige zahl sein
hat man sich dann auf diese auch diese
systematik wir gucken bei den familien
nach und wir gucken dass diese familien
auch anerkannt sind und dann kommt man
zusammen mit den griechischen behörden
auf diese 400 familien mit den 1500
personen machte es wir hören mal was die
cdu dazu zu sagen hat beziehungsweise
einer ihrer ministerpräsidenten nämlich
herr kretschmann ministerpräsident von
sachsen der hat folgendes dazu gesagt
wir wollen helfen und das muss man auf
verschiedene weise tun einmal ganz
konkret vor ort auf der anderen seite
gibt es eben besonders schutzbedürftige
familien ältere menschen menschen
erkrankt sind und da ist dieses zeichen
jetzt mit den 1500 menschen schon eines
was auch eine wirkung erzielen wird so
finde ich hier in die kommentare gucke
dann sehe ich einerseits viele
unqualifizierte kommentare dann möchte
ich doch noch mal ein mäßig und bitten
aber eben auch genau die sorge die mein
kollege mathis feldhoff in berlin gerade
schon angesprochen hatte ich niemals
einen kommentar heraus von andreas
schwartz auf facebook der schreibt genau
der falsche weg frau merkel und herr
seehofer hier in unserem google
doktorsee uns teilen die redaktion
schreibt mir die kommentare da rein sie
öffnen die türen für flüchtlinge wie
2015 das darf nicht noch mal passieren
gesagt wird bis zu 1500 menschen
und am ende sind es 10.000 menschen
jetzt kann natürlich schlecht sagen
mathis feldhoff wie viele menschen
tatsächlich so denken in deutschland
aber ist diese stimme wird bei der union
immer noch mit gedacht und mit gehört ja
natürlich wird sie mit gedacht und mit
gehört man muss ja wissen dass sozusagen
2015 nicht nur sozusagen zu einer hand
stieg von rechten stimmen von
populistischen stimmen
stichwort afd in der bundes blick
deutschland gesorgt hat sondern auch die
union selber also cdu und csu ran an den
rand der zerreißprobe geführt hat
wahrscheinlich waren diese parteien noch
nie so zerrissen sie zu diesem zeitpunkt
und sie haben aus dieser erfahrung
gelernt dass sie wenn die schritte gehen
auch humanitäre schritte gehen dass sich
die mit mäßiger umgehen müssen das den
menschen erklären müssen
und das tun sie glaube ich gerade so zu
sagen und ein schritt wie in vs kind
verlangt hat wie er möglicherweise aus
sicht der spd auch logisch ist der ist
für die union momentan nicht gangbar und
deswegen ist sie da hat sie da zur
mäßigung aufgerufen hat sich
möglicherweise an der stelle auch was
die mäßigen angeht durchgesetzt
allerdings sie hat sich nicht
durchgesetzt sozusagen das ist gar keine
neuen flüchtlinge gibt jetzt ist
natürlich die frage wie das weitergeht
siehst du die wogen zwischen spd und
union jetzt
geglättet und das wird erst mal wieder
einen burgfrieden hergestellt oder
könnte das noch weiter schwelen
naja mein eindruck ist dass insbesondere
der vizekanzler und kanzlerkandidat in
der spd sich durchgesetzt hat und da
auch dafür gesorgt hat dass man jetzt
sozusagen wegen und ich sag mal sehr
leipzig und möglicherweise auch ein
bisschen zynisch wegen ein paar
flüchtlingen die auf einer weit
entfernten griechischen insel sitzen bei
deren stellen schicksal wirklich
schrecklich ist aber dass man deswegen
natürlich jetzt nicht ein jahr vor der
wahl die koalition einfach mal kurze
infrage stellen kann
allen beteiligten ist doch klar dass man
dieses nächste jahr sozusagen als bruder
auch angesichts der kroner krise noch
vernünftig zu ende kriegen muss dass man
reagieren muss dass man dieses land am
laufen halten muss und dass dafür auch
die koalition insgesamt gebraucht wird
und da kann man sich nicht über die
flüchtlingsfrage zerstreiten das ist dem
vizekanzler der spd glaube ich ziemlich
klar und deswegen ist am ende die spd
auch eingeschränkt auf diesem kurs
mathis feldhoff vielen dank für diese
einschätzung und ersten informationen zu
dieser meldung die heute nachmittag über
die nachrichten ticker kam ich guck mal
bei uns kurz in die kommentare
so ein bisschen weil die spaltet sich
natürlich das ganze wieder es gibt
einerseits die menschen die sagen ist es
viel zu vieles geht es gar nicht
andere sagen längst überfällig erst
recht wenn man sich weigert menschen von
dashboard auf lesbos ausreisen zu lassen
das wird zu fast die flüchtlinge sind
spielball der politik so jetzt hatte ich
eigentlich max ist schon verabschiedet
er ist immer noch da das macht aber
nichts
dann sollte ich an bald stößt vielen
dank für deine einschätzungen und sehen
hier schauen einmal weiter auf die insel
lesbos dort einigermaßen es ist laut
hinter ihnen die ich sehe
und auch höhere können sie ganz kurz
mehr erzählen was sich hinter ihnen
abspielt
ja ich bin hier auf einer kundgebung von
der vom arbeiter zentrum von der linken
gewerkschaft eine veranstaltung pro
geflüchtete die darauf auch besser
machen möchte auf die ganzen probleme
die die brote die geflüchteten hier vor
ort haben dies denn die nager aktuell
vor ort auf gleis forst ich habe
mitbekommen dass sind zelte aufgebaut
worden einige hundert sind auch schon
eingezogen dabei wo ist der rest der
rest lebt nach wie vor noch auf der
straße auf den straßen
einerseits dem abgebrannten games moorea
und andererseits auf der straße ziemlich
in der mitte zwischen mit hinnehmen und
im camp in moriya einige hundert
eingezogen und der rest sollen nach und
nach jetzt auch einziehen können die
menschen nicht einziehen weil noch
nichts da ist oder wollen die nicht
einziehen
die menschen wollen nicht einziehen das
war die meinungen der letzten tage ganz
klar von den leuten wobei einfach viele
leute auch mittlerweile einfach so müde
und so zermürbt sind und das
wahrscheinlich auch nicht aus zufall
dass mittlerweile viele leute wenn man
dadurch geht und viel deutsch spricht
von vielen ein von allen leuten gefragt
und was wir machen sollen wir das mal
kern gehen sollen wir hier bleiben was
sollen wir tun
was passiert mit uns ist die nachricht
dass deutschland knapp 1550 menschen
aufnehmen will schon durchgesickert in
der flüchtlings reihen oder ist das noch
nicht bekannt tatsächlich nachdem diese
zahl 1500 ja schon mal im märz im raum
stand und danach ja nicht allzu viel
passiert ist habe ich ehrlich gesagt
nicht den mut gehabt den leuten diese
hoffnung in aussicht zu stellen
das heißt was glauben sie was passiert
wenn man dem jetzt quasi sagt 1550
kommen von allen griechischen inseln
zusammen nach deutschland schon ein
genehmigungsverfahren haben dass wir
dann passieren
na ja die hoffnung die hoffnung keimt
einfach wieder auf die leute hoffen auch
immer wieder aufs neue hoffnung mit
immer wieder zerstört durch einfach alle
eine unfassbar unmenschliche behandlung
ihnen gegenüber und na ja sie haben ja
gesagt es sind ja nicht nur ein leute
aus moriya sondern nicht aus sondern von
einem griechischen inseln womit ich
nicht sagen will dass die menschen auf
den anderen
inseln natürlich nicht weniger wert sind
jetzt kommen hier kommentare natürlich
bei uns wieder einen livestream nicht
nur einen vorerst brennen sie ihr
eigenes camp geräumt und ein neues ziel
wie ist die stimmung unter den
flüchtlingen was diesen brand angeht ist
es wird es hingenommen wird das
kritisiert oder wird das nach wie vor
befürwortet oder wie wir das generell
sind kann man da kann einiges ablesen
also erstmal vielleicht ganz kurz zu dem
kommentar erstmal ist noch nicht
bewiesen das ist gefühlte selber waren
und dann dazu auch letztendlich so
gewesen wäre
waren es ein paar wenige damit kann man
ja nicht pauschal über alle menschen
urteilen das ist für mich völlig
unverständlich waren so wie man so
denken kann
die stimmung unter den leuten ist ja
sehr angespannt auch natürlich in der in
der bevölkerung auf der insel weil die
leute einfach auch sehr müde sind von
der standespolitik war denn auch
jahrelang in sachen versprochen sind
willig eingehalten worden sind und diese
gewalt oder diese diese wut oder dieser
der ärger schlägt leider auch der unter
einheimischen immer häufiger in gewalt
um
die bewährten sie jetzt als aktivist von
mission live nein wir versuchen menschen
aus seenot zu retten und dann für sich
dafür aussprechen dass sie asyl in
europa bekommen wie bewerten sie jetzt
die beschlüsse der bundesregierung also
erst mal ich bin kein politischer
aktivist und ich bin nicht noch eine
politische motivation dann auch in der
sozialen motivation hier aber meine
persönliche meinung ist dass man das
sehr sehr kritisch hinterfragen muss
eben weil ich wie ich schon gesagt habe
diese zahl 1500 märz schon mal im raum
stand davon wurde ja auch schon dann
irgendwie zwischendurch 400 leute
aufgenommen ich weiß nicht ob diese 400
jetzt aufgenommen wurden von diesen
neuen 1500 abgezogen wurden dann
komplett 2005 insgesamt von den
kritischen
also wie viele leute am ende wirklich
hier diese insel verlassen dürfen
das bleibt erstmal abzuwarten und
deshalb habe ich selber gar keine große
aufgaben viel weniger würde ich jetzt in
die wand unter den opfern machen wollen
kommen denn weiterhin menschen an an auf
lesbos oder ist er hat sich das quasi
gerade ein bisschen gelegt weil die
menschen wissen sie haben sowieso keine
möglichkeit auf lesbos unterzukommen es
zurzeit kommen sehr wenige boote an man
bekommt sehr wenig mit was auch ganz
bewusst so kommuniziert wird ich weiß
nicht kommuniziert wird
die boote es gibt immer wieder gerüchte
und informationen das neue boote
abgestuften wollen so genannten push
bergs durchgeführt werden sollen
aber natürlich bekommen die leute auf
ihre antwort durch ihre handelt werden
dass sie dass sie mir zu trinken
bekommen dass sie nichts zu essen
bekomme ich infos bekommen michael jäger
markt kopfsprung hat dazu ein video
gemacht aber da bekommen die leute
natürlich schon mit was passiert
passiert und wie die leute hier
behandelt werden
wenn man ruinen die stimmung in
deutschland kommt auch in die kommentare
in den kommentarspalten liest kommt
immer wieder die befürchtung dass das
schule machen würde dass das ist ja auch
eine haltung der griechischen regierung
wenn flüchtlinge quasi ein zeltlager
oder einige wenige ein zeltlager
anzünden das zu brandstiftung und kommt
das ganze lager abbrennt und dann quasi
die schlussfolgerung ist dass menschen
aus europäische festland dürfen dass das
schule machen würde
wie sehen sie das ist es da wie sehen
sie die gefahr gegeben oder so
dieser situation wie sie jetzt haben so
unzufrieden dass sie sich was sie sich
erhoffen dass so etwas nochmal passiert
nein also nochmal erst mal gibt es die
beweise noch gar nicht dass das hier
wirklich leute geflüchtet war
da haben sie recht ja danke für die
korrektur ja dann auch noch mal dass
selbst wenn es gelänge welche gewesen
sind dann waren das ein paar wenige und
es wird halt über alle pauschal
beurteilt und das darf einfach
mich interessiert aber wir stehen unter
den menschen dort also wie sprechen die
über diesen brand meine geschlitterten
ja ja ja das war ein großes drama also
dass das finden die leute ganz schlimm
denn wir haben natürlich nicht gerne in
bogel gewohnt aber wenn man von einer
von einer noch erbärmlicher struktur
sprechen kann hatten sie dort eine
struktur und leute haben jetzt gar
nichts mehr bekommen nicht kann ich zu
essen nicht zu trinken heute gab es gar
nichts zu trinken für die menschlichen
einmal am tag vielleicht was zuerst
dafür müssen die stundenlang bei 35 grad
in der standen schlange anstehen es gibt
keine sanitäranlagen keine medizinische
versorgung also dass das das finden sie
bestimmt nicht gut dass das alte cannon
abgebrannt dann danke ich ihnen die herr
fischer für eindrücke von mir im sinne
des oswald von der demonstration unter
ihnen sind auch für das sie bis heute
gerade erleben
das ist keine demonstration vielen dank
dann fasst noch einmal zusammen was
heute von der bundesregierung
beschlossen und verkündet wurde es
werden insgesamt 1500 53 menschen aus
408 familien die bereits schutz
berechtigt sind also von griechenland
als berechtigt anerkannt worden sind in
deutschland aufgenommen
150 unbegleitete minderjährige
asylsuchende sollten ja schon nach
deutschland kommen dass es letzte woche
bereits angekündigt worden
das heißt ein etwas kleineres kontingent
als das was die spd vorsitzende saskia
esken ursprünglich mal gefordert hatte
sie hatte von einer höheren
vierstelligen zahl gesprochen damit
konnte sich nicht durchsetzen aber im
endeffekt gibt es jetzt eine einigung
zwischen spd und union diese menschen
aufzunehmen und es gibt auch noch das
war eine meldung den bisschen
untergegangen ist die ankündigungen dass
man in einer koalition der willigen
darüber sprechen möchte vielleicht noch
mehr
schon aus griechenland zu holen das ist
aber alles noch relativ im wagen
geblieben die neue eu flüchtlingspolitik
die anberaumt ist oder die zumindest
beraten werden soll
ursprünglich am 31 september geplant
soll das auch ein paar tage vorgezogen
werden das heißt es ist bewegung im
thema und wir werden daher
wahrscheinlich in den nächsten tagen und
wochen öfter dazu live streams machen
heute abend sage ich aber erstmal vielen
dank fürs zu sehen
machen sie's gut und tschüss